Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. films football beer and above all gambling filled up the horizon of their minds to keep them in control was not difficult so said george orwell in his dystopian masterpiece 1984 football or soccer to our american listeners for so long seen as the sport of the proles, has emerged as the single strongest element of modern day popular culture, breaking out from its working class stronghold and capturing the imagination of men and women of all ages and all classes. How did this happen and what does it mean that we have replaced nearly all forms of combat with the spectacle of 22 men kicking a ball around?
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。电影、足球、啤酒，最重要的是赌博，充斥着他们思想的视野，要让他们保持驯服并不困难——乔治·奥威尔在他的反乌托邦杰作《一九八/四》中曾这样写道。足球（对我们的美国听众来说是英式足球）长期以来一直被视为无产阶级的运动，如今却已成为现代流行文化中最强大的元素，打破了其工人阶级的坚固阵地，俘获了各个年龄段、各个阶层男女的心。这是如何发生的？我们用22个人踢球的奇观取代了几乎所有的战斗形式，这又意味着什么？
With me is Dominic Sandbrookok keen football fan hello tom responded in your your wolves shirt yeah or gold big wolves fan um one of the founding uh one of the founding clubs of the english football league of course and uh in the premiership yeah um i i'm a big um biller fan also one of the 12 founding clubs of the English Football League and in the Premiership. And joining us is Jonathan Wilson, who is a Sunderland supporter. Jonathan, Sunderland's neither of those two things, is it? Well, we call it the Premier League now, Tom, as I'm sure you're aware. And actually, you touch on a very, I think,
与我一同做客的是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，他是一位狂热的足球迷。你好，汤姆。听到这话，你正穿着狼队的球衣吧？是的，黄金色的，狼队的超级球迷。嗯，英格兰足球联盟的创始俱乐部之一，当然也是英超联赛的创始俱乐部之一。没错。嗯，我也是维拉的超级球迷，同样是英格兰足球联盟和英超联赛的12家创始俱乐部之一。与我们同行的还有乔纳森·威尔逊，他是一位桑德兰球迷。乔纳森，桑德兰可不属于这两者中的任何一个，对吧？好吧，我们现在叫它英超联赛了，汤姆，我相信你是知道的。实际上，你触及了一个非常，我认为……
immediately you hit upon a critical point, which is, was the English league, as founded in 1888, really a national league when certain teams were banned from entering for being too far away? Can we really count Preston's two titles in those first two seasons as genuine league titles when essentially it was a Lancaster, or a Lancashire-West Midlands combination, a regional league.
你立刻切中了一个关键点，那就是：作为1888年创立的英格兰足球联盟，当某些球队因路途遥远而被禁止加入时，它真的算是一个全国性的联盟吗？我们真的能把普雷斯顿在前两个赛季获得的两个冠军视为真正的联赛冠军吗？因为从本质上讲，它只是兰开夏郡（Lancashire），或者说兰开夏郡-西米德兰兹的联合会，一个地区性的联赛。
Sunderland, of course, in their first season in the league, did exceptionally well and went on to win it three times in the first five seasons. This is precisely the way I knew he would behave if he'd got it on the podcast. And Tom, don't get me started on the 1913 FA Cup final because we know how Villa cheated there. Yeah, and so immediately I've given the ball away.
当然，桑德兰在加入联赛的第一年表现极其出色，并在头五个赛季中三次夺冠。这完全符合我预料中他带着这个上播客时的表现。而且，汤姆，别跟我提1913年的足总杯决赛，因为我们都知道维拉当年是怎么作弊的。没错，所以就这样，我立刻把球权拱手让人了。
Wilson has broken and has scored already i mean the 1913 fa cup final between villa and sonland was so controversial jonathan they couldn't even play the charity shield the following august because sonland refused to take part because they're so outraged and i i hope you feel uh the requisite shame for that tom tom never feels any shame i can assure you of that so so so those listeners um who who are not familiar with jonathan's incredible work um on multiple football and sporting podcasts um in the media author of a range of fantastic books on football um jonathan um i wanted to ask you for those those who are familiar with your work and who may not even like football, is football a worthwhile object of study for historians?
威尔逊已经带球突破并完成破门了。我是说，1913年维拉和桑德兰之间的足总杯决赛争议太大了，乔纳森，以至于他们甚至无法在同年8月举办慈善盾杯，因为桑德兰拒绝参加，他们实在是太愤怒了。我……我希望你为那件事感到应有的羞耻，汤姆。汤姆从来不会感到羞耻，我可以向你保证这一点。所以，所以，所以那些对乔纳森在多个足球和体育播客中的不可思议的著作、在媒体上的杰出工作不熟悉的听众们，作为一系列关于足球的出色书籍的作者，乔纳森，我……我想问你，对于那些熟悉你的作品、甚至可能并不喜欢足球的人来说，足球对历史学家来说是一个值得研究的对象吗？
And I'm going to give you a quote from the great historian Robert Coles, whose book for Sporting Life came out last year and i read a couple of weeks ago excellent book and he says about sport generally but this would work very well for football i think it is a major subject not in itself perhaps but in the way it is woven into almost everything else we do and he talks of sport and again by extension football one of england's great civil cultures so um this is obviously a history podcast not a sport podcast how would you convince people who who know nothing about football who might be skeptical about having this as a subject for a podcast that it's it's worthwhile for historians to look at i mean so on the one hand football is entirely trivial you know i recognize that the the details of who won what when and who scored which goals when
我要引用伟大历史学家罗伯特·科尔斯的话，他的书《体育生活》去年出版了，我几周前读过，是一本极好的书。他谈到一般意义上的体育，但这同样非常适用于足球，我认为：“它是一个重大课题，或许不是就其本身而言，而是因为它融入了我们所做的几乎所有其他事情之中。”他将体育，同样引申开来即足球，称为英国伟大的文明文化之一。所以，这显然是一个历史播客，而不是一个体育播客。你将如何说服那些对足球一无所知、可能对将此作为播客主题持怀疑态度的人，让他们相信历史学家研究足球是很有价值的？一方面，足球完全是微不足道的，你知道的，我承认谁在什么时候赢了什么、谁在什么时候进了什么球的这些细节……
is largely irrelevant. But, I mean, David Goldblatt in his book, The Age of Football, which came out, what, two years ago, he makes the point that football now is the most universal cultural mode there has ever been. It is everywhere in the world.
在很大程度上是无关紧要的。但是，大卫·戈德布拉特在他两年前出版的书《足球时代》中指出，足球现在是历史上最普遍的文化形态。它存在于世界的每一个角落。
I mean, I remember I was in Ethiopia in 2015 in Lalabela, and I was there to see the rock churches. And on the Saturday afternoon at lunchtime, I was in a restaurant and said, I quite want to watch Chelsea v Liverpool today. Where can I do it? And the restaurant manager said, oh, well, I'm knocking off.
我的意思是，我记得2015年在埃塞俄比亚的拉利贝拉，我当时是为了去看岩石教堂。在周六下午的午餐时间，我在一家餐厅说：“我今天挺想看切尔西对利物浦的比赛。在哪里能看？”餐厅经理说：“哦，好吧，我要下班了。”
Come with me. We went to this cafe. There's about 200 people in this cafe watching the TV. And then he said, well, if you want the real experience, we should go to one of the video halls. So we went then to watch Swansea v Arsenal. And there was just a big screen at the front of this, I don't even know what you call this,
“跟我来。”我们去了这家咖啡馆。咖啡馆里大约有200人在看电视。然后他说：“嗯，如果你想获得真正的体验，我们应该去其中一个录像厅。”于是我们去看了斯旺西对阿森纳的比赛。在这个地方的正前方有一个大屏幕，我甚至不知道该怎么称呼这个地方……
a muddy bank with seats hammered into the bank. I would say probably 500 people in there. There was sort of tarpaulin over the top. You had to pay five beer or whatever to get in, you know, a notional fee. To me, I guess locals, it probably was quite significant. And this was one of three of these halls in this kind of quite small village. And there's all these cafes.
一个带有钉着座位的泥泞河岸。我估计里面大概有500人。顶部搭着某种柏油帆布。你得付五块啤酒钱或其他什么才能进去，你知道的，象征性的费用。对我来说，我猜对当地人来说，这可能相当重要。而且这是这个相当小的村庄里三个这种大厅中的一个。还有所有这些咖啡馆。
So I worked out that 20% of the male population, of the adult male population of of this village in Ethiopia, or watching the Premier League on any given Saturday afternoon. So this is something that takes up a huge amount of the emotional intellectual space of a huge number of people. And that then I think has two interesting consequences. So one is the very direct consequence of how politicians try to use football as a tool of propaganda. And the other is the point that Galeano makes, Eduardo Galeano, the Uruguayan poet, politician, theorist, who, as you know, Tom, I have severe doubts about. But the point he makes
所以我计算了一下，在埃塞俄比亚这个村庄里，有20%的男性人口，即成年男性人口，在任何给定的周六下午都在观看英超联赛。因此，这是一项占据了大量人情感和智力空间的事物。我认为这随之产生了两个有趣的结果。一个是政客们如何试图将足球用作宣传工具的非常直接的结果。另一个是加莱亚诺——乌拉圭诗人、政治家、理论家爱德华多·加莱亚诺——所提出的观点，正如你所知，汤姆，我对他是存有严重怀疑的。但他提出的观点是……
that show me how you play and I'll tell you who you are, I think is very significant. That the way a culture's teams, the way a culture plays football, I think can tell you quite a lot about that culture, particularly when it's self-conscious as it is in the case of, say, Argentina. If I can just jump in, thinking about it from a historian's point of view, Tom, when you write about the Romans,
“展示你是如何踢球的，我就会告诉你你是谁”，我认为这非常有意义。一个文化的球队、一个文化踢球的方式，我认为可以告诉你很多关于那个文化的信息，尤其是当它具有自我意识时，比如在阿根廷这种情况下。如果我可以插话的话，从历史学家的角度来考虑，汤姆，当你书写罗马人时，
it would be weird for you not to mention gladiatorial games or chariot racing or any of the sort of the hobbies and the things that fascinated ordinary Romans. And for me, writing about post-war Britain, I mean, most people at any given moment didn't give a damn about the social contract or the details of Harold Wilson's plan to revive the economy, or indeed Margaret Thatcher's monetarist policies, the way they understood and structured their lives was obviously about a personal narrative, but it's often about a narrative that's not about political events. It's about sporting events or cultural events, music.
如果你不提及角斗士比赛、战车赛，或者任何令普通罗马人着迷的业余爱好和事物，那对你来说才是一件奇怪的事。对我而言，在书写战后英国时，我的意思是，在任何特定时刻，大多数人都根本不在乎社会契约、或哈罗德·威尔逊振兴经济计划的细节，甚至不在乎玛格丽特·撒切尔的货币主义政策。他们理解和构建生活的方式，显然关乎个人叙事，但它通常关乎一种并非关于政治事件的叙事。它关乎体育事件、文化事件、音乐。
And to not take people's lives in their own terms and understand what matters to them, I think it's actually to miss what life was about but to put that to ask jonathan i mean so the romans they have their gladiatorial sports um you know the greeks have their athletics the peoples of mesoamerica have that have their ball games um but football is coming out of a presumably, a specific cultural context, a national context. It does presumably matter that it emerges specifically from England.
如果不按照人们自己的条件去审视他们的生活，不理解对他们而言重要的事情，我认为这实际上就是错失了生活的真谛。但抛开这一点来问乔纳森，我的意思是——罗马人有他们的角斗士运动，希腊人有他们的田径，中美洲的人民有他们的球类游戏——但足球似乎是从一个特定的文化背景、一个国家背景中走出来的。它显然很重要，因为它具体是从英格兰发源的。
I mean, or could it just have emerged from anywhere? I mean, Jonathan, wasn't the thing that FIFA said that actually its origins lay in China or something? Have I misremembered that? I remember them saying that. I remember Sepp Blatter making that point very explicitly. Sorry, go ahead, Trough. Well, I mean, of course, Sepp Blatter would say whatever. Sepp Blatter making that point very explicitly. Sorry, go ahead, Trough. Well, I mean,
我的意思是，或者它本可以从任何地方发源？我的意思是，乔纳森，国际足联不是说过其实它的起源在中国之类的地方吗？我是不是记错了？我记得他们说过这个。我记得塞普·布拉特非常明确地提出了这一点。抱歉，你继续，汤姆。好吧，我的意思是，当然，塞普·布拉特会说任何……塞普·布拉特非常明确地提出了这一点。抱歉，你继续，汤姆。好吧，我的意思是，
of course, Sepp Blatter would say whatever. Sepp Blatter is the former president of FIFA,
当然，塞普·布拉特会说任何话。塞普·布拉特是国际足联的前任主席，
which is the governing body of the sport. He would say whatever was useful to him politically at the time.
而国际足联是这项运动的管理机构。他会说任何在当时对他的政治立场有利的话。
I mean, Sepp Blatter saying something is almost certainly guaranteed it's not true rather than the reverse.
我的意思是，塞普·布拉特说的话几乎可以百分之百保证不是真的，而不是相反。
So it's not true? China didn't invent football what is clearly true is that lots of different cultures practice ball sports so we have
所以这不是真的？中国没有发明足球？显然真实的情况是，许多不同的文化都进行球类运动，所以我们有……
I think it's 5,000 years ago in China which does appear to be the earliest evidence we find but there's also stories of I remember going to the Roman fort
我认为这是5000年前的中国，这似乎是我们能找到的最早证据，但也有一些故事……我记得小时候去南希尔兹的阿尔贝亚罗马堡垒时，有人告诉我那里的罗马士兵会踢他们在战斗中斩首的敌人的头颅。我想在哥伦布的航海日志中，他记录了当他到达……
in South Shields to Arbea as a kid and being told that Roman soldiers there would kick around the heads of their enemies who they decapitated in battle. I think in Columbus's logs, he notes when he gets to the
加勒比群岛时，他看到岛民们在玩一种用橡胶球的游戏。很显然，球类运动存在于许多不同的文化和许多不同的形式中。我们今天所知的足球，非常明显地源于1863年末在伦敦科芬园附近的共济会酒馆（Freemasons' Tavern）举行的一系列会议。这些会议是由那些从学校和大学走出来的球队代表们发起的，他们试图统一为一种比赛。但每所学校、每所大学……
Caribbean islands, he sees islanders playing a game with a rubber ball. So clearly ball sports have existed in many different cultures and many different forms. Football, as we know it today, very clearly comes from a series of meetings held at Freemasons Tavern near Covent Garden in London in late 1863, which were an attempt by representatives of teams who would come out of the schools and universities to try and get one game. But each school, each university
都有其自身的足球形式，他们想要一套统一的规则，这样当你从你的学校来到大学时，就不会就“什么是足球”展开长时间的争论，你有一套可以遵循的规则。这些学校是公立学校（public schools）。好吧，正如我所说，这正是引人入胜的地方，不是吗？从一开始，你在所谓的“工人的比赛”与精英的、你知道的，进行了法规编纂的公立学校起源之间，就存在着这种张力。难道你不认为这种张力一直都存在吗？是的，这种张力绝对一直都存在，因为制定这些规则的人正如你所说，他们来自公立学校，而成立的第一家俱乐部却在谢菲尔德……
had its own form of football and they wanted a unified set of laws so that you know when you came from your school you got to university you didn't have these long arguments about what football was you had a set of laws you could play by these schools are public schools well as i say that's the fascination isn't it that from the start you have this tension between the so-called working man's game and the elite you know public school origins of the codified game don't you think that tension's always been there yeah that tension has absolutely always been there because the people who were who were setting those laws are as you say they're from the public schools uh whereas the first club founded is in sheffield um you know It had been founded a few years earlier.
你知道的，它几年前就已经成立了。那是一家工人阶级的俱乐部，一家工人的俱乐部。所以，是的，这种张力一直都存在。当然，这就是为什么你会围绕职业化产生巨大的争论，职业化最终在1885年合法化。所以，乔纳森，关键其实在于规则。因为想必你也有那些可以追溯到中世纪的古老传统，当时城镇里的人们只是在街上踢猪膀胱之类的东西。那其实是有组织的混乱。没有什么规则。
And that was a working class club, a working man's club. So, yeah, that tension has always been there. And, of course, this is why you get the huge arguments over professionalism, which eventually is legalised in 1885. So, Jonathan, the key thing really is about laws, because presumably also you have these kind of ancient traditions that go back to the Middle Ages of towns just kind of kicking pigs' bladders through the streets or whatever. And that's kind of organised chaos, really. There aren't rules.
我的意思是，这就是规则：没有规则。而在19世纪，不只是足球，还有板球、橄榄球、网球，所有这些运动，真正使它们成为后来样子的，是规则的编纂。维多利亚时代的人显然在规则编纂方面有着巨大的天赋，因此，在任何有意义的意义上，现代足球都源于1863年的这些会议。如果你看看他们制定的12条规则，它们与我们今天的规则惊人地相似。我的意思是，经历了一系列改变，特别是在最近一段时间，但本质上，这些规则与今天的足球是一样的。现在，我认为这是关于这些学校在玩的这些游戏是什么的另一个有趣的角度。它们似乎源于村庄的暴民足球（mob game）。为什么会有这些游戏？通常它们会在忏悔星期二（Shrove Tuesday）或其他某个节日举行，两个村庄或同一个村庄的两半人会进行一场比赛，其中包括试图把一个猪膀胱……
I mean, that's the rule. There are no rules. Whereas in the 19th century, it's not just football, it's cricket, rugby, tennis, all these sports. It's the codification that really makes them what they become. and the victorians clearly had this great gift for codification and and so you know in any meaningful sense modern football comes from these meetings in 1863 and if you look at the 12 laws they they draw they're remarkably similar to what we have today i mean there's been a series of changes particularly recently um but essentially, those laws are recognisable as football as it is today. Now, I think this is another interesting avenue of what are these games
或者一麻袋干草、或者无论你碰巧是什么球的东西，从一端弄到另一端。关于这种现象为什么会发展起来，有各种各样的理论。其中最有趣的理论之一——我的意思是，这看起来似乎很有道理，但显然无从得知——是这某种程度上是丰产仪式（fertility rite）的遗留。因此，因为球门，可以说是……
that the schools are playing? And they seem to derive from a mob game of the villages. And why did you get these games? Normally, they'd be held on, say, Shrove Tuesday or some other feast day, that two villages or two halves of the same village would play a game, which would involve trying to get a pig's bladder
在这些早期的比赛中，通常是地面上的洞，将一个球形物体放入洞中，代表了太阳对大地的受精，然后这就产生了一个巨大的讽刺：为什么公立学校……我对此表示怀疑。好吧，是的，我对此表示怀疑，但这……不过是个伟大的理论，对吧？我相信詹姆斯·弗雷泽（James Fraser）一定会相信这一点的。
or a sack of hay or whatever your ball happens to be from one end to the other. And there's various theories as to why that should have grown up. One of the most interesting of which, which I mean, it seems plausible, but obviously there's no way of knowing, is that this is some sort of vestige of a fertility rate. And so because of the goals, as it were,
因为，你知道的，对詹姆斯·弗雷泽来说，一切都是丰产仪式。但随后你有一个美丽的讽刺：在公立学校里，驱动体育运动的是什么？为什么体育如此重要？为什么它是课程的核心？那是“肌肉基督教”（muscular Christianity）。这是一种这样的理念：你想让男孩们为了管理帝国而变得强壮，但同时又有一种对他们所谓的“自慰”（solipsism），即手淫的极度恐惧。
in these early games are often holes in the ground, the placing of a spherical object in the hole represents the fertilisation of the earth by the sun, which is then this great irony that why do the public schools... I'm sceptical. Well, yeah, I'm sceptical, but it's... It's a great theory, though, isn't it? I'm sure James Fraser would have believed this.
如果你把一个男孩独自留在一旁，他就会沉溺于这种使人衰弱的行为中。所以你需要他在场上和其他一大群男孩一起奔跑，表现出一场丰产仪式。好吧，在汤姆插话之前，我要插话问一个如果我对他放任不管、他毫无疑问会问关于“肌肉基督教”的问题。所以许多，嗯，至少相当大一部分这类最初的俱乐部是由教堂创立的，对吧？所以基督教一直是……你会说这是为了社会控制吗？
Because, you know, for James Fraser, everything was a fertility rate. But then you have this beautiful irony that in the public schools, what drives sport? Why is sport so important? Why is it so central to the curriculum? And it's muscular Christianity. It's this idea that you want to toughen boys up for running the empire, but also this terrible fear of what they call solipsism, i.e. masturbation,
试图驯服不断增长的工业城市中汹涌的激情？你认为这是其中一部分原因吗？可能有一部分这方面的原因。我认为人们也认识到体育是健康的，例如比喝酒更健康。你在不同的国家以不同的形式看到了这一点。例如，俄罗斯最早的俱乐部之一……
that if you leave a boy alone, he's going to partake of this debilitating act. So what you need is him to be running about on a field with loads of other boys performing a fertility rite. Well, before Tom gets in, I want to get in and ask the question that he undoubtedly will ask if I leave him unchecked about muscular Christianity. So a lot of the, well, certainly a large number of this sort of original clubs were founded by churches, weren't they? So Christianity was always, was it because of social control, would you say,
是由查纳克（Charnak）兄弟创立的，他们来自布莱克本。他们在莫罗佐夫磨坊（Morozov Mills）经营莫罗佐夫纺织厂，就在莫斯科郊外。他们建立了一个足球俱乐部，因为如果他们不这么做，他们的工人们就会在周六下午……
trying to sort of domesticate the surging passions of the growing industrial cities? Do you think that's part of it? There may have been some of that. I think also there was a recognition that sport was healthy, healthier than drinking, for instance. And you see this in various forms in various countries. So, for instance, one of the earliest clubs in Russia
狂饮伏特加。他们认识到踢足球对工人们来说比那更好，所以我认为有一种感觉，即……
is founded by the Charnak brothers who are from Blackburn. They ran the Morozov Mills these textile mills just outside Moscow and they set up a football club because if they didn't their workers spent Saturday afternoons
足球作为一项运动，其本身就是一种善。然后我认为迷人的是，这是19世纪由肌肉基督教传播的一种理念，但在两次世界大战之间的中欧，它是由“肌肉犹太主义”（muscular Judaism）传播的。所以，举个例子，维也纳的哈科亚（Hakoah）是维也纳专门的犹太复国主义俱乐部。
just knocking back the vodka and they recognised that playing football was better for them than that so I think there's sort of a sense that
他们在1925年赢得了奥地利联赛冠军。但他们存在是为了弘扬肌肉犹太主义，并为犹太复国主义筹集资金。回到你刚才说的，乔纳森，关于实业家将足球传播到俄罗斯，足球联赛的12家创始俱乐部基本上都是兰开夏郡和米德兰兹的俱乐部。所以非常像是工业革命的跳动心脏。你想想……你知道的，俱乐部的昵称，枪手（gunners）、铁锤帮（hammers）等等——我的意思是，这些都是工业名称。足球在英国诞生时——我们谈到了公立学校传统——但它真的——我的意思是，其基石是它是一项工业运动吗？它是为产业工人、工业城镇准备的运动。
football is a sport is a good in and of itself. And what I think is then fascinating is that this is an idea propagated by muscular Christianity through the 19th century, but then between the wars in Central Europe, it's propagated by muscular Judaism. And so you have, for instance, Chakorach, who are the specifically Zionist club of Vienna.
这样说公平吗？是的，我想是的。我的意思是，你肯定会看到早期的、早期取得成功的俱乐部所在的城镇，都是米德兰兹和北方的所有大型工业城镇和城市。我的意思是，直到1931年我们才有了一个伦敦的冠军。所以联赛始于1888年。我认为这……
And they win the Austrian League in 1925. But they are there to promote muscular Judaism and to raise funds for Zionism. And just going back to what you, Jonathan, what you were saying about industrialists spreading football to Russia, the 12 founding clubs of the Football League are basically Lancashire and Midlands clubs. So very much the kind of the beating heart of the Industrial Revolution. And you think about the you know the nickname for for clubs gunners and hammers and so on i mean these are industrial names is is is is football as it emerges in britain we talked about the public school tradition but it but is really i mean the kind of the bedrock is is that it's an industrial sport it It's a sport for industrial workers, industrial towns.
具有重要意义，你可以看到……这是一种在世界各地重复出现的模式：在极权国家，成功总是集中在首都。在大多数民主发达国家，则是大型工业城镇。直到后来，资本变得更加集中于首都时才有所改变。所以你在意大利会看到，例如，都灵和米兰是两个成功的城市。相比之下，罗马根本不成功。但你会看到这种模式在重复，即成功的是省会城市。我不知道这是否是因为工业有什么特殊之处——显然，足球作为一项观赏性运动的发展中的关键因素之一是《工厂法》（Factory Act），它赋予了工人们周六下午的假期。所以他们要做什么呢？给他们提供足球去观看，
Would that be fair? Yes, I think so. I mean, you see certainly the early, the towns that have clubs that are successful early are all the big industrial towns and cities of the Midlands and North. I mean, we don't have a London champion until 1931. So the league begins in 1888. And I think that's
还是因为有一种感觉，即省会城市需要表达它们的身份，需要……你知道的，足球俱乐部已经成为地方自豪感的表达，因此人们对俱乐部进行了投资。这可能是这两个因素的混合体。像毕尔巴鄂这样的人不正是如此吗？我的意思是，你知道的，这些地方将自己定义为与……与中心的对立面。
significant that you sort of see... This is a pattern that's repeated across the world, that in totalitarian states, success is always focused on the capital. In most democratic developed countries, it's the big industrial towns. And it's only later when capital becomes much more focused on the capital. So you see in Italy, for instance, Turin and Milan are two successful cities. Rome is not successful at all by comparison. But you see that pattern repeated, that it's the provincial cities. And I don't know whether that's because there's something specific about industry and obviously one of the key things in the growth of football as a spectator sport is the factory act which gives workers a the Saturday afternoon off so what are they going to do give them football
是的，与国家大都市的对立。我的意思是，毕尔巴鄂是一个非常特殊的情况。我的意思是，竞技俱乐部（Athletic），是西班牙仅有的三支从未降级的俱乐部之一，考虑到他们的预算，这简直不可思议。但很明显，他们承载了大量的……巴斯克民族主义的分量。是的，毕尔巴鄂竞技是一个非常特殊的情况。显然，巴塞罗那也承载了加泰罗尼亚民族意识的理念。既然我们已经走出国门，让我们来谈谈足球的出口。所以足球大概是伴随着帝国传播的。
to go and watch or whether it's a sense that provincial cities need to express their identity need you know the football club has become an expression of local pride and so there's investment in the club. And it's probably a mix of those two factors. That's true of someone like Bilbao, isn't it? I mean, you know, these places that define themselves in opposition to the sort of... To the centre.
它伴随着，什么，商船？不，不，我其实不认为那是真的。因为如果你看看那些大型帝国的、大型殖民地，澳大利亚、加拿大、印度。好吧。大型殖民地……你知道的，澳大利亚、加拿大、印度。好吧，乔纳森，我有一个问题要问你，来自一个名叫西蒙·沙玛（Simon Schama）的热刺球迷——据我所知，他可能也写过一些陈年历史。他偶尔涉猎，不是吗？他偶尔涉猎，但他主要的焦点是……是足球。他问：为什么足球没有像板球那样，在19世纪的大英帝国成为风靡一时的运动？老实说，我不知道，但我想这可能与阶级有关，
Yeah, to the national metropole. I mean, Bilbao is a very specific case. I mean, Atletico, one of only three clubs in Spain, never to have been relegated, which given their budget is incredible. But obviously they take on a whole huge amount of weight of
因为足球成功开拓的地区，可以说是你可以称之为非正式帝国的地方。比如阿根廷，就是一个很好的例子：尽管它从未成为帝国的一部分，但那里显然有着巨大的英国影响力。英国经营着肉类产业和加工厂、资金供给、银行系统。我的意思是，法国人似乎控制了码头，但英国对阿根廷显然有着巨大的政治和经济影响。
Basque nationalism. It's yeah, Atletico in Bilbao is a very particular case. Obviously, Barcelona has taken on the idea of Catalan nationalhood as well. So now that we've moved abroad, let's talk about the export of football. So football presumably follows the empire.
英国在那里或者说英国的影响力——其实是苏格兰的影响力——是巨大的，这是因为建立的学校，是因为在快速工业化的布宜诺斯艾利斯运营的公司。所以我认为……
It follows, what, the merchant ships? No, no, I don't think that's true, actually. Because if you look at the big imperial, the big colonies, Australia, Canada, India. Okay. the big colonies you know australia canada india okay could i jonathan i've got a question for you from um a spurs fan called simon sharma who i gather has also may have written the old history he dabbles doesn't he dabbles but his main focus is is uh is football um and he asks why didn't football take off as the sport of the 19th century British Empire while cricket did? The honest answer is I don't know, but I wonder if it's something to do with class,
六支球队之一——我不认为是在第一年，但我认为是阿根廷联赛成立的第二年或第三年（阿根廷联赛成立于1890年代初）。其中一支球队是一家苏格兰管道公司，他们去那里是为了铺设污水处理工程。所以这非常……
because where football is explored successfully is in what I guess you could call the informal empire. Something like Argentina, for instance, is the great example that, although it was never part of the empire, there was clearly enormous British influence there. Britain ran the meat industry and the processing plants and the money supply, the banking system. I mean, the French seemed to have controlled the docks, but Britain clearly had an enormous political and economic influence over Argentina.
有组织的足球在那里非常具有英国特色，但它迅速发展起来。然后你在1913年拥有了第一个阿根廷本土的阿根廷冠军。
And the English influence or the British influence there, it's a Scottish influence really, is enormous and that's because of the schools that are founded, it's because of companies working in the sort of rapidly industrialising Buenos Aires. So I think
所以在此之前一直都是英裔冠军。直到1913年，竞技俱乐部（Racing Club）赢得冠军，我的意思是，这绝对是……
one of the six teams who, I don't think in the first year but I think it's the second or third year in the Argentinian League, which was founded early 1890s. One of the teams is a Scottish plumbing company who were there to put in the sewage works. So it's very much,
象征性的绝佳时刻，因为这是英国开始从阿根廷撤退的时刻，伴随着第一次世界大战的到来，
organized football is very British there, but it rapidly takes off. And what you then have is in 1913 you have the first Argentinian Argentinian champion
阿根廷开始掌控自己的事务，并且在那个时期，阿根廷进行了巨大的讨论：“什么是阿根廷？（que es Argentina）成为阿根廷意味着什么？”所以莱奥波尔多·卢戈尼斯（Leopoldo Lugones），20世纪初阿根廷伟大的诗人之一，
so you had Anglo champions all the way through 1913 Racing Club wins the title and this is I mean it's absolutely
在1912年发表了一系列关于这个主题的演讲，即“什么是阿根廷”。从足球的角度来看，为什么这很引人入胜的原因是，统一这个庞大而分散的国家的事情中极少的一件——你拥有一个新国家，土著居民在19世纪末的一系列种族灭绝战争中基本被消灭了。
the right moment symbolically because this is the moment at which Britain begins to retreat from Argentina and the coming of the First World War
第一次世界大战开始时，你看看阿根廷的人口构成：一百万西班牙人、八十万意大利人、四十万北欧犹太人、四十万阿拉伯人、四万德国人、三万法国人、三万英国人和爱尔兰人，全部来自截然不同的地方，对生活应该是什么样有着截然不同的想法。但他们所有人的一致共识是，当身穿蓝白相间条纹球衣的球队与智利、乌拉圭或巴西进行比赛时，他们希望这支球队赢。想必潜藏在背景中的，也是一种宣扬对英格兰的独立文化独立的方式。不仅不是在背景中，我的意思是绝对在前台。这也是为什么很多关于足球国家风格的讨论，我认为可能有点站不住脚。但在阿根廷，它是绝对核心。
and Argentina sort of takes of the First World War and Argentina sort of takes control of its own affairs and you have around that time this huge discussion in Argentina of que es Argentina, what is it to be Argentinian? So Leopoldo Lagones, one of the great poets of the early 20th century in Argentina,
所以首先，足球是英国的进口货。因此，竞技俱乐部赢得冠军对阿根廷来说是一个巨大的时刻，意味着：“好吧，我们在1816年赢得了对西班牙的独立，但这是一种某种新的独立。”然后“什么是阿根廷”这个问题变得很棘手，因为卢戈尼斯将其归结为高乔人（gaucho），
gives a series of lectures in 1912 on exactly the subject, que es Argentina. And the reason why this is fascinating from a football point of view is that one of the very few things that unifies this, this great disparate nation, you have a new nation, the indigenous populations essentially wiped out in a series of genocidal wars in the late 19th century.
那个在潘帕斯草原上控制着庞大牛群的牛仔。你可以理解为什么这很有吸引力。
And the beginning of the first world war, you look at the, the, the makeup of Argentina and it's a million Spaniards, 800,000 Italians, 400,000 Northern European Jews, 400,000 Arabs, 40,000 Germans, 30,000 French, 30,000 British and Irish, all from very different places, very different ideas of what life should be. But what they all agree on is that when the team in the blue and white stripes plays a match against chile or uruguay or brazil they want them to win and presumably also hovering in the back is um a way of asserting independent cultural independence from england well not even in the background i mean absolutely in the foreground and this is again this is what a lot of talk about national styles of football i think can be a little bit tenuous. With Argentina, it is absolutely central.
高乔人是一个非常浪漫的人物。他拥有极高的精湛技艺，但他孤独、勇敢、与恶劣环境抗争。但问题是，高乔文化到1912年已经消亡了，而英国人杀死了它。英国人引入了铁丝网。一旦有了铁丝网，你就不需要高乔人了。所以在19世纪中前期，高乔人的政治影响力被一个名叫亨利·牛顿（Henry Newton）的人摧毁了，他引进了铁丝网。然后当你二三十年后得到带刺铁丝网时，那对于把牛圈在正确的地方显然更好了。因此，阿根廷文学的伟大史诗是《马丁·菲耶罗》（Martin Fierro），它在1870年代分两卷出版。而那关于……它确实正处于高乔时期的末尾。我的意思是，
So to begin with, football is a British import. And so wrestling winning the title is a huge moment for Argentina saying, OK, we had our independence from Spain in 1816, but this is some kind of new independence. And then this question of chaos in Trinidad is problematic because Lugones locates it in the gaucho,
我认为这是一部对高乔文化表现得相当矛盾的作品，但人们当然并没有真正去读它。他们只是喜欢高乔人的概念。所以你会发现在19世纪10年代末和20年代初，布宜诺斯艾利斯出现了高乔人俱乐部，人们穿着他们想象中高乔人应该穿的服装，去参加这些巨大的阿萨多（asados）烤肉聚会。
the cowboy who's controlling the great herds of cattle across the pampas. And you can see why that's attractive.
而阿萨多烤肉，至今仍是阿根廷社会生活极其重要的一部分。你会看到像博尔赫斯和阿道夫·比奥伊·卡萨雷斯（Adolfo Bioy Casares）这样的人，他们公开嘲笑这种做法，说道：“你知道的，高乔人根本不会这样穿衣。你打扮得像鲁道夫·瓦伦蒂诺。你打扮得一点都不像高乔人。”
The gaucho is this very romantic figure. He has this great virtuosity, but he's solitary, he's brave, he's battling the elements. But the problem is the gaucho culture is dead by 1912 and the British have killed it. The British import wire. And as soon as you have wire fences, you don't need a gaucho. So the political clout of a gaucho in the early to mid 19th century is destroyed
人们逐渐认识到，在一个日益城市化的社会里，这种做法隐约显得荒谬，高乔人已经没有容身之地了。那么，你在哪里可以找到高乔人的精神呢？它在街头顽童（pibe）身上找到了。你在二十年代风靡一时、极具影响力的足球杂志、体育杂志《图画报》（El Grafico）中看到了一系列文章，
by a man called Henry Newton, who brings in wire. And then when you get barbed wire 20 or 30 years later, that's obviously even better for keeping your cows in the right place. So the great epic of Argentinian literature is Martin Fiera, which is published in two volumes in the 1870s. And that's about, it's really right at the end of a gaucho period. And it's, I mean,
指出街头顽童以及顽童踢球的方式，某种程度上代表了阿根廷的灵魂。二十年代的文章指出，街头顽童以及顽童踢球的方式，某种程度上代表了阿根廷的灵魂。这显然与英国相对立，因为英国足球——正如由英国人在阿根廷所传播的那样——是通过学校进行的。它是在那些宏伟的草坪球场上进行的。它关乎奔跑和力量。如果事情失控，那里有一位拿着哨子的老师来控制局面。而顽童在波特雷罗（Potrero）踢球……
I think it's quite an ambivalent work about gaucho culture, but of course people don't actually read it. They just like the idea of a gaucho. So you find in the late 19-teens and early 1920s, you get gaucho clubs in Buenos Aires where people dress in their idea of what a gaucho would look like, and they go to these huge asados, the huge barbecues.
在不断扩张的城市的空地上。他在坚硬不平的地面上踢球。可能是一个小场地上每边有二三十个人。你必须能够控制球。
And the asados, grilling meat, is still an enormous part of Argentinian social life. And you get people like Borges and Adolfo Boixasaras, who sort of openly laugh at this, saying, you know, a gaucho wouldn't have dressed like this. You're dressed as Rudolph Valentino. You're not dressed as a gaucho.
你必须具备技术造诣。你必须能够照顾好自己。你必须具有这种精明市侩的性格。那里没有拿着哨子在事情失控时制止它们的老师，你必须能够照顾好自己，你必须具有这种精明市侩的性格。你必须能够照顾好自己。
And there's a recognition this is vaguely preposterous in an increasingly urban society that the gaucho has no place. So where can you find that spirit of a gaucho? And it's found in the pibé, in the urchin of the street. And you get a series of articles in El Grafico, a hugely successful influential football magazine,
你必须手腕强硬（肘下生风）。于是，顽童成为了这个新的高乔人。他是城市环境中的高乔人。他是这种精神的代表。这就是马拉多纳，对吧？然后，在1928年，你看到了著名的社论……
a sports magazine, through the 1920s, pointing out that the pibé and the way the pibé plays football, that is somehow representative of the soul of Argentina. 1920s, pointing out that the Pee-Bay and the way the Pee-Bay plays football, that is somehow representative of the soul of Argentina. And this is clearly in opposition to Britain because the British football, as is propagated
由博尔科托（Borocotó）撰写，他像大多数阿根廷人、大多数伟大的阿根廷人一样，实际上是个乌拉圭人，他是《图画报》的编辑。他写了一篇文章说：“如果你为阿根廷足球的精神竖起一座雕像，”
by the British in Argentina, was through the schools. It's on these great grassy playing fields. It's about running and about strength. You have a teacher there with a whistle if things get out of hand to control things. The Pee Bay playing on the Potrero
“那就是那个留着一头未驯服的黑发、牙齿因吃昨天的面包而磨损、背心被忧虑的老鼠咬得破烂不堪的街头顽童。”
on the vacant lot of the growing city. He's playing on this hard uneven surface. It's maybe 20, 30 a side on a tiny pitch. You've got to be able to control the ball.
他的脸上带着滑稽可笑的微笑，眼中闪烁着光芒。如果你把这段描述给某个人听：“这是谁？”100%的人都会说那是迭戈·马拉多纳。而这发生在马拉多纳国际比赛首秀的49年之前。这就是为什么马拉多纳的出现自带光环。
You've got to have technical virtuosity. You've got to be able to look after yourself. You've got to have this streetwise character. There's no teacher there with a whistle to stop things when they get out of hand, you've got to be able to look after yourself, you've got to have this streetwise character. There's no teacher there with a whistle to stop things when they get out of hand. You've got to be able to look after yourself.
他带着预言的力量降临。他就像回答以西结召唤的基督。我想裁判时间到了。我听到裁判的哨声了。我们休息一下，回来后交换场地，看看下半场会带来什么。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
You've got to have sharp elbows. And so the P-Bay becomes this new gaucho. It's a gaucho in an urban environment. It's the representation. This is Maradona, right? And then you get, in 1928, you get the famous editorial
我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告音频、加更节目和提前获取现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。好吧，这是一个分为上下半场的播客。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。
by Bob Cotto, who, like most Argentinians, most great Argentinians, is actually Uruguayan, the editor of El Grafico. And he writes this piece saying, if you erect a statue
我们正在与足球作家兼历史学家乔纳森·威尔逊交谈。让我们把话题转向现代比赛及其作为一项全球性运动的地位。我们这里有一个来自布鲁诺·莱特（Bruno Leiter）的问题：“当人们踢足球时，可以说世界在文化挪用我们的文化吗？足球是我们送给世界最伟大的礼物吗？”我的意思是，很难想到有什么英国软实力工具比这更伟大。很难想到有什么英国发明被如此多的不同国家和文化所接受。当然，从收视率和电视转播权的层面来看，英超联赛遥遥领先地……
to the spirit of Argentinian football, it's the pibe with his mane of untamed black hair, his teeth worn down by eating yesterday's bread, his vest eaten away by the mice of care.
是世界上最成功的联赛。但它真的还是一个英格兰联赛吗？许多球员不是英国人，许多教练不是英国人，许多俱乐部老板不是英国人，许多观众也不是英国人。这实际上给我们带来了一个相当棘手的张力：究竟什么是足球俱乐部？因为我在桑德兰长大。我是一个桑德兰球迷。桑德兰是我与23年前离开的家乡之间关系的表达。
And he had a picaresque smile on his face, a twinkle in his eye. And if you gave somebody that description, who is this? 100% of people would say it's Diego Maradona. And this is 49 years before Maradona makes his international debut. And that's why Maradona comes with this.
我和父亲的关系几乎完全是通过足球维系的。我们一起做的唯一一件事就是去看球赛。我现在为什么还要回东北部？是为了见朋友和去看球赛。我们一起做的唯一一件事就是去看球赛。我现在为什么还要回东北部？是为了见朋友和去看球赛。如果那里没有足球，我可能就不会去见那些朋友了。
He comes with a force of prophecy. He is Christ answering Ezekiel's call. I think it's time for the referee. I hear the referee's whistle. Let's have a break and we'll come back and change ends and see what the second half brings. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
所以对我而言，我猜对许多在英国或不列颠北部省级城镇长大的其他人来说，足球是我们处理与家乡关系的一种方式。这是我们身份中非常深刻的一部分。而且要想赢得任何荣誉比以往任何时候都更难。当我们录制这段节目时，距离一场重要的杯赛决赛只有两天了，
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Well, it's a podcast of two halves. Welcome back to The Rest Is History.
这可不是什么只属于小球队的不值一提的破烂玩意儿。那是那种什么“漆布奖杯”（paint trophy）之类的吗？那是什么？是锦标赛奖杯（Chequeatrade）。我简直不敢相信你这样贬低棒约翰奖杯（Papa John's Trophy）。棒约翰奖杯。所以我的内心有一部分想说：“是的，足球属于在俱乐部周围成长起来的社区。”
We're talking to football writer and historian Jonathan Wilson. Let's pivot to the modern game and its place as a global sport. We've got a question here from Bruno Leiter. Can we say the world is culturally appropriating our culture when football is played? Is football our greatest gift to the world? I mean, it's hard to think of any greater tool of British soft power. It's hard to think of any British invention that's been taken on by so many different countries and so many different cultures. And of course, the Premier League is by a long way
而且，你知道的，许多俱乐部在他们自己的社区里做了很多伟大的社会工作。但与此同时，我真的能转过身去对班加罗尔那个从五六岁起就熬夜到很晚、观看他深爱的曼联比赛、每周省下一点钱的孩子说——当他30岁时，他终于买得起去老特拉福德观看曼联1比1伯恩利比赛的旅行。我真的能说他支持曼联的权利或他的归属感比我少吗？
the most successful league in the world in terms of viewership and in terms of TV rights. But is it really an English league anymore? A lot of the players aren't British, a lot of the managers aren't British, a lot of the club owners aren't British, and a lot of the viewers aren't British. And that actually presents us with quite a difficult tension as to what is a football club. Because I grew up in Sunderland. I'm a Sunderland fan. Sunderland is an expression of my relationship with a home
我认为你真的不能这么说。我认为这引发了如此多有趣的问题，但我只想切入其中一个。这是全球化问题的核心，对吧？确实如此。但关于时间线的问题……我的意思是，我们都是在同一时期长大的，大致是70年代、80年代初。
I left 23 years ago. My relationship with my dad was almost entirely conducted through football. It was the one thing we did together was to go and watch football. Why do I go back to the Northeast now? It's to see mates and go and watch football. It was the one thing we did together was to go and watch football. Why do I go back to the Northeast now? It's to see mates and go and watch football. And if a football wasn't there, I probably wouldn't go and see those mates.
我23年前离开的。我和我爸的关系几乎完全是通过足球维持的。我们俩一起做的事就是去看球。为什么我现在还要回英格兰东北部？就是为了见朋友和去看球。我们俩一起做的事就是去看球。为什么我现在还要回英格兰东北部？就是为了见朋友和去看球。如果没有足球的话，我可能就不会去见那些朋友了。
So for me, and I suspect many other people who grew up in provincial northern towns in England or Britain, football is a way of processing our relationship with our homes. It's a very profound part of our identity. And worse than ever to win anything. And as we record this, we're two days from a major cup final,
所以对我来说，我猜对许多在英国或不列颠北部省份小镇长大的其他人来说，足球是我们处理与家乡关系的一种方式。这是我们身份认同中非常深厚的一部分。而且赢得任何冠军都比以往任何时候都重要。就在我们录音时，距离一场重大杯赛决赛还有两天，
which isn't just some tin pot little thing that's only for small teams. It's one of those paint trophies or something. What is it? It's the chequered trade. I can't believe you demean the Papa John's trophy like that. Papa John's trophy. And so part of me wants to say, yeah, football is for the community that's grown up around the club.
这可不仅仅是什么微不足道、只属于小球队的破烂玩意儿。比如什么油漆奖杯之类的。到底是什么？是锦标赛奖杯。我不敢相信你这样贬低棒约翰奖杯。棒约翰奖杯。所以我的内心一部分想说，是的，足球是为了在俱乐部周围成长起来的社区服务的。
And, you know, a lot of clubs do a lot of great social work in their own communities. But at the same time, can I really turn around to the kid in Bangalore who has grown up from the age of five or six, going to bed late at night to watch his beloved Manchester United and he saves up a little bit every week. And eventually when he's 30, he can afford his trip to go to Old Trafford to watch Manchester United 1, Burnley 1. Can I really say that his right to support United or his sense of affiliation is any less than mine?
而且，你知道，许多俱乐部在他们自己的社区里做了很多伟大的社会工作。但与此同时，我真的能对班加罗尔那个从五六岁起就熬夜看他深爱的曼联、每周攒点零花钱的孩子说不吗？等他30岁时，他终于攒够钱去老特拉福德看曼联1比1战平伯恩利。我真的能说他支持曼联的权利或归属感比我少吗？
And I don't really think you can say that. I think this raises so many interesting questions, but one I just wanted to get in on. It's the nub of the issue of globalisation, right? It is. But one on the chronology, though. I mean, we all grew up at the same time, roughly, sort of 70s, early 80s,
我觉得你不能这么说。我觉得这引发了太多有趣的问题，但我只想切入其中一个。这就是全球化的核心问题，对吧？确实如此。不过关于时间顺序，我是说，我们差不多都是在同一个时期长大的，大概是70年代到80年代初，
at a point when English football was widely thought to be dying. And actually, having written about 70s, 80s Britain, you know, writing the story, it often surprises me that it didn't. Because attendances were in free fall the game was associated overwhelmingly in the public mind not just in britain but around the world with hooliganism you know england disgraced themselves at tournament after tournament with their hooligan behavior english fans disgraced themselves again and again were banned from europe
在人们普遍认为英格兰足球正在走向消亡的时期。事实上，写过70和80年代的英国后，你知道，写这段历史时，我常常感到惊讶它竟然没有消亡。因为当时上座率直线下降，公众脑海中的这项运动——不仅在英国，在全世界——都与足球流氓行为紧密相连。你知道，英格兰人在一场又一场的比赛中因流氓行为而丢脸，英格兰球迷一次又一次地丢脸，被逐出欧洲赛场
in 1985 and at that point i, if you were a betting man, you would say this is a dead sport. It's a Victorian sport, born in industry, in the world of the church, in muscular Christianity, all of which have gone. Why will it endure? And actually the question is, why did it endure? Why didn't it die?
在1985年，当时如果你是个好赌的人，你会说这是一项死去的运动。这是一项维多利亚时代的运动，诞生于工业时期、教堂的世界、肌肉基督教，而这些都已不复存在。为什么它能延续下去？事实上问题是，为什么它能延续下去？为什么它没有消亡？
Yeah, I mean, you're absolutely right. It seems to me incredible that my mam let me go and watch football. Because there's the three major disasters. You have a Bradford fire, which kills 56 people in 1985. Then Heysel, which is Liverpool versus Juventus in the European Cup final. Hooliganism leading to a wall collapsing, killing 38 Juventus in the European Cup final hooliganism leading to a wall collapsing killing 30 38
是的，我的意思是，你完全说得对。在我看来，我妈妈竟然让我去观看足球比赛，这简直不可思议。因为有三大灾难。你经历了布拉德福德球场火灾，1985年导致56人丧生。然后是海瑟尔惨剧，那是欧洲冠军杯决赛中利物浦对阵尤文图斯。足球流氓行为导致一堵墙倒塌，在欧洲冠军杯决赛中导致38名尤文图斯球迷丧生，足球流氓行为导致一堵墙倒塌导致30 38
Juventus fans and then you have Hillsborough in 89 the terrible crush in 90 96
名尤文图斯球迷丧生，然后是89年的希尔斯堡惨剧，90 96年的可怕踩踏事件
killed in an FA Cup semi-final which was to do with crowd safety issues and the design of the stadium and policing rather than hooliganism per se although of course if it hadn't been hooliganism there wouldn't have been fences
在足总杯半决赛中丧生，这与球场安全问题、球场设计和警务有关，而不是足球流氓行为本身，当然，如果没有足球流氓行为，看台前面就不会有防护栏
at the front of the stand um so yeah the idea that and some of the some of the things i saw as a kid going to football i mean i remember quite clearly being i don't know must have been 15 or 16 being in a game at birmingham and seeing something i wouldn't say he was a mate but I knew him we were in the car driving away from the game saw him getting punched in the face and his jaw was broken
嗯，所以是的，那种想法以及我小时候去看球时看到的一些事情——我的意思是，我记得非常清楚，我不知道，当时大概15或16岁，在伯明翰的一场比赛中，看到了一些事情，我不会说他是朋友，但我认识他，我们当时正开车离开比赛现场，看到他的脸挨了一拳，下巴被打断了
and you saw him go down and you sort of think should we stop and help and then he's like no we can't I remember being at Derby once stopped at traffic lights and people kicking
你看到他倒下，你有点觉得我们应该停下来帮忙吗，然后他说不，我们不能。我记得有一次在德比，在红绿灯处停下，有人在踢
in the side of the car and you went back every week and I've got no idea why we did that it seems bizarre that we did it and you're right the stadiums were crumbling. There's a smell of urine about everything.
车身，而你每周都回去，我完全不知道我们为什么那样做，这看起来太离谱了，而且你说得对，球场正在坍塌。到处都是尿骚味。
There was that sense of hostility the whole time. And then that begins to change early 90s that you have a Taylor Report which mandates all-seater stadiums for top flight clubs, which clearly does a lot to make ground safer. It makes crowd control a lot easier. It makes the environment a lot more comfortable. It begins to attract different people. It led to a rise in prices, which, I mean, Lord Justice Taylor specifically says
那种充满敌意的感觉一直都在。然后这种情况在90年代初开始改变，泰勒报告强制顶级俱乐部使用全坐席球场，这显然对提高球场安全性起了很大作用。它使人群控制变得容易得多。它使环境更加舒适。它开始吸引不同的人。它导致了价格上涨，我的意思是，泰勒勋爵特别指出
there is no reason for a rise in prices, but prices double mean, Lord Justice Taylor specifically says there is no reason for a rise in prices, but prices double over the course of three or four years, which again clearly affects the makeup of who's going. You also have Italia 90, which from an English point of view, I think has a huge effect on how we viewed football and somehow... Because it becomes associated with opera
价格上涨没有理由，但价格在三四年内翻了一番，这显然再次影响了去球场的人的构成。你还有意大利之夏（Italia 90），从英格兰的角度来看，我认为它对我们看待足球的方式产生了巨大的影响，不知怎么地……因为它与歌剧联系在了一起
rather than with paganism. Well, yeah, and things, moments, you know, it's a great moment of national unity of everybody watching a team actually, an England team actually playing well in a major tournament, which was the first time it happened in my lifetime. And also Gazza's tears and
而不是与原始野蛮联系在一起。嗯，是的，还有一些事情、时刻，你知道，这是一个伟大的国家团结时刻，每个人都在看一支球队，实际上是一支英格兰球队在一个重大赛事中踢得很好，这在我有生之年还是第一次发生。还有加扎的眼泪和
the sense that masculinity didn't have to be aggressive. It could be this softer side to it. But also that it is in Italy and you have got Pavarotti and it suddenly comes to be associated with rather desirable middle-class Mediterranean holidays rather than with kind of, I don't know, kind of rainy subways and wolves or whatever.
那种男子气概不一定非要是攻击性的感觉。它可以有更柔和的一面。但也因为它在意大利，有帕瓦罗蒂，它突然开始与令人向往的中产阶级地中海假期联系在一起，而不是某种，我不知道，下雨的地铁和狼队之类的。
What is this? I mean, that sounds like that was your experience of it, Tom. And I'm sure that that was what people thought. I mean, in the 90s, it becomes a middle class sport as well as a working class sport. Is that the cliche or is that not true? Because I think middle class people had always liked football, but they hadn't gone. Yeah, I think they'd watched it on TV. So when TV, there is an argument among football historians
这是什么？我的意思是，听起来那是你的经历，汤姆。我确信这也是人们的想法。我的意思是，在90年代，它既成为了一项中产阶级运动，也成为了一项工人阶级运动。这是陈词滥调还是事实并非如此？因为我认为中产阶级一直都很喜欢足球，但他们没有去现场。是的，我想他们在电视上看。所以当电视出现时，足球历史学家之间存在一种争论
that what happens when TV comes in is TV actually sort of nationalises football. And middle-class people who wouldn't have gone to games and now watch. So at my prep school, which was basically a Victorian school preserved in Aspig in 1980s England, every boy had a team, collected football stickers, watched on TV, but virtually none went to games.
当电视介入时，电视实际上将足球“全国化”了。那些原本不会去现场看球的中产阶级现在开始观看了。所以在我的预科学校里——这基本上是一所保留在1980年代英格兰阿斯皮格的维多利亚式学校——每个男孩都有一个球队，收集足球贴纸，在电视上观看，但实际上没有人去现场看球。
And they were all pretty sort of middle-class West Midlands children. So I think already there was a middle-class element. But maybe Jonathan would agree that what changed in the 90s was that they actually started to go to the games. Yeah, I mean, I think a lot had already gone to the games. I mean, I was middle lot had already gone to the games. I mean, I was middle class of some denomination
而且他们基本上都是西米德兰兹郡的中产阶级儿童。所以我认为其中已经包含了中产阶级元素。但乔纳森也许会同意，90年代改变的是他们真正开始去现场看球了。是的，我的意思是，我认为很多人已经去现场看球了。我的意思是，我带有某种身份的中产阶级
and I went, my dad had always gone, his dad had always gone. I mean, there's a story my dad used to tell. Sunderland played Manchester United in 1964 in an FA Cup replay and the official attendance was 64,000, but the gate collapsed and God knows how many got in.
我去过，我爸爸一直去，他爸爸一直去。我的意思是，我爸爸经常讲一个故事。1964年桑德兰对阵曼联的足总杯重赛，官方上座人数是64,000人，但球门看台倒塌了，鬼知道有多少人挤了进去。
But my dad worked sort of, I don't know, a mile from me. His mother lived very close to the 200 yards from Rucker Park and he worked about a mile away. So he would walk home at night, he'd go and have his tea and he'd go to the stadium. And because there's so many people there this night, he couldn't get home. And so he went to the ground in his suit carrying a briefcase.
但我爸爸工作的地方，我不知道，离我有一英里远。他母亲住在离鲁克公园球场非常近的地方，大约200码，他工作的地方大约有一英里远。所以他晚上会步行回家，吃完茶点然后去球场。由于这天晚上人太多，他无法回家。于是他穿着西装、提着公文包去了球场。
And his story was always, he saw all these other blokes in suits carrying their briefcases because they'd all found exactly the same problem. So I think, I don't know if figures actually exist for this, but I think it's far too easy to suggest that 80s purely working class sport, 90s purely middle class sport, but certainly the proportion changes.
他常讲的故事是，他看到所有其他穿着西装、提着公文包的家伙，因为他们遇到了完全相同的问题。所以我想，我不知道这方面是否有实际的数据，但我认为把80年代纯粹视为工人阶级运动、90年代纯粹视为中产阶级运动，这种说法太简单化了，但比例确实发生了变化。
And you also get things like All Played Out, Fever Pitch, Football Against the Enemy, these three canonical works of football literature, which persuade publishers, for instance, that football is something that the reading classes want to read about. I think football coverage in the newspapers changes. I think what you see as a decade goes on. So you get kind of Oxford graduates writing about it.
你还会看到诸如《全场比赛》、《极度狂热》、《极地恶球》这三部经典的足球文学作品，它们说服了出版商，例如，足球是阅读阶层想要了解的内容。我认为报纸对足球的报道发生了变化。我认为随着十年的推移，你所看到的是。你会看到牛津毕业生在撰写相关文章。
Yeah, you get post-lancers like me writing about it. People like you. But this is actually quite a serious kind of shift. And I came slightly too late for this, but within the press box, there were a lot of tensions around the turn of the millennium between the old school who had not gone to university and the new university-educated football writers. And one of the reasons that you suddenly get this wave
是的，你会看到像我这样的大后方一代在写这个。像你这样的人。但这实际上是一个相当重大的转变。我来得稍微晚了一些，但在媒体席上，千禧年之交时，那些没有上过大学的老派记者和受过大学教育的新派足球记者之间存在着很多紧张关系。你突然迎来这股浪潮的原因之一
of university-educated football writers is that football writing is suddenly seen as a desirable profession in a way it never would have been in the 80s or early 90s. And you have Sky and the Premier League as well. That's the other factor. But yeah, come on. But could I also ask about the structure of employment and the gradual impact of capital,
受过大学教育的足球记者突然被视为一份理想的职业，这是80年代或90年代初绝对不会有的。而且你还有天空电视台和英超联赛。这是另一个因素。但是，是的，来吧。不过我也可以问一下就业结构和资本的逐渐影响吗？
which is the kind of Marxist perspective that I know Dominic will be keen to explore. I love that kind of stuff. Love it. He would have been in the early 90s, wouldn't he? Basically, basically. I mean, football in England for most of the 20th century is based on a kind of apprentice system, isn't it?
这是一种马克思主义视角，我知道多米尼克会很乐意探讨。我喜欢那种东西。太喜欢了。他在90年代初就会这样，对吧？基本上，基本上。我的意思是，在20世纪的大部分时间里，英格兰的足球都是基于一种学徒制度，不是吗？
It's, you know, you get Bobby Moore turning up when he's 15 and cleaning out the toilets and things. And even Billy Wright hanging out with his landlady, even when he's captain of England. And the amount of money that footballers are earning is minusc compared to to what they then go on to earn what is it that change how is it that that footballers go from from basically earning the amount of money that that a skilled manual worker would be earning in the 50s and 60s to to kind of being stratospheric earners now what's that what's the process that in it that facilitates that well you had a maximum wage until 1961 which was 20 pounds a week season, £18 a week out of the season. And that was flat across the board.
你知道的，博比·摩尔15岁时就去清理厕所之类的。甚至比利·赖特在担任英格兰队长时也和他的女房东混在一起。足球运动员的收入与他们后来所能获得的收入相比简直微不足道是什么改变了这一切，为什么足球运动员的收入从50和60年代基本上相当于熟练体力工人的收入，变成了现在天文数字般的收入，促成这一转变的过程是什么？好吧，在1961年之前，我们实行最高工资制，赛季期间每周20英镑
So you might have played 100 times for England or you might be a talented 17-year-old and you would get 20 quid a week. And obviously some people earned less than that. And then a series of court cases and that maximum wage is lifted. Famously, Johnny Haynes immediately goes to £100 a week at Fulham, which is largely published by Tommy Trinder,
赛季外每周18英镑。而且这个标准是全行业统一的。
the great musical impresario who ran Fulham. But even then, you didn't get huge wages. So Manchester United and Liverpool, you had Matt Busby and Bill Shankly, the two managers, and Shankly certainly promoted this sort of, football is this great socialist ideal. And yet they stitched it up to now be earned more than 35 quid a week if you played Manchester or Liverpool.
所以你可能为英格兰队出场100次，或者你可能是一个有天赋的17岁球员，你每周也只能拿20英镑。显然有些人赚得比这还少。随后经历了一系列诉讼，最高工资限制被取消了。众所周知，约翰尼·海恩斯在富勒姆立刻拿到了每周100英镑的薪水，这在很大程度上是由汤米·特林德宣传的
So Shankly was just as exploitive when he had the need to be as anybody else. I mean, football is beyond anything else a game of profound hypocrisy and always has been. But you also then have what was called the retain and transfer system where a club would hold your license to play.
这位管理富勒姆的伟大音乐剧 impresario。但即便如此，你也没有拿到很高的工资。所以曼联和利物浦，你有马特·巴斯比和比尔·香克利这两位主教练，香克利当然宣扬了这种足球是伟大社会主义理想的理念。然而他们却暗中操纵，如果你为曼联或利物浦效力，每周的收入也不会超过35英镑。
So even if you even if you want to leave even if you're refusing to play they could stop you signing for another league club. And that only ended beginning of the 80s. And then you have
所以香克利在有需要的时候和其他人一样具有剥削性。我的意思是，足球比其他任何东西都更是一场充满深刻伪善的游戏，而且一直都是如此。但随后你还有所谓的保留与转会制度，即俱乐部拥有你的比赛注册权。
the Bosman ruling comes in in, what, 96, which means anybody who's out of contract is entitled to a free transfer rather than the fee being set by a tribunal. And that gives players much more power to determine their own futures. So it's a kind of liberalising,
所以即使你想离开，即使你拒绝踢球，他们也可以阻止你签约另一家联赛俱乐部。这种情况直到80年代初才结束。然后你有了博斯曼裁决，在96年左右出台，这意味着任何合同到期的球员都有权自由转会，而不是由仲裁法庭设定转会费。这赋予了球员更多决定自己未来的权力。所以这是一种自由化的过程
liberalising of trade structures. It's Thatcherism. It is. I think what's really striking, Tom, is how late footballers move to genuinely wealthy levels. So if you read accounts of footballers in the seventies and eighties, the sort of Kevin Keegan's and Trevor Brookings, I mean, they would give interviews to football magazines
贸易结构的自由化。这就是撒切尔主义。确实是。汤姆，我觉得真正让人印象深刻的是，足球运动员直到很晚才真正达到巨富的水平。所以如果你读到七八十年代足球运动员的报道，比如凯文·基冈和特雷弗·布鲁金，我的意思是，他们会接受足球杂志的采访
and they would show you inside their lovely home and they'd show off their new lawnmower and their kind of, you know, their, their Austin Allegro or whatever. And their lives were really not so different from, you know, a reasonably prosperous kind of middle class, you know, middle manager. Yeah, I mean, you look at Bobby Charlton. Bobby Charlton, I think, is one of the more sensible footballers. And when he decided he was going to become a footballer at age 15, he leaves Ashington to go to Manchester United and there's an uncle of his ran a green grocers
他们会带你参观他们可爱的家，向你展示他们的新割草机，还有他们的那种，你知道的，他们的奥斯汀阿莱格罗汽车或其他什么。他们的生活其实和那种，你知道的，一个相当富裕的中产阶级，你知道的，中层管理者没有太大区别。是的，我的意思是，看看博比·查尔顿。博比·查尔顿，我认为是一个比较理智的足球运动员。当他决定在15岁成为一名足球运动员时，他离开阿辛顿前往曼联，他的一个叔叔经营一家蔬菜水果店
and he said to him how much do I need to set up a green grocers and this uncle says about £2,000 and so Bobby Charlton thinks right 20 year career I'll save up £100 a year and then buy a green grocers when I'm finished Well that was a classic thing wasn't it run a sports shop, run a pub I mean I remember in late 90s, so at a point where football was starting to earn
他问他开一家蔬菜水果店需要多少钱，叔叔说大约2000英镑，于是博比·查尔顿心想，好吧，20年的职业生涯，我每年存100英镑，等我退役时就买一家蔬菜水果店。这真是经典的套路，对吧？开个体育用品店，开个酒吧。我的意思是，我记得在90年代末，也就是足球开始赚钱的时候
about, what, £20,000 a week, perhaps something like that, talking to an American historian friend of mine about this. And I did this sort of stock thing that people did, which is to say, it's terrible they earn so much, you know, the sort of performative outrage, if you like. And he said, what I can't understand as an American is how they earn so little. There is so much money in this game, and compared with the US sports stars, why on earth is it taking so long
大约每周2万英镑左右，也许类似这样的数字，我和一位美国历史学家朋友谈过这事。我当时做了人们常做的那种标准反应，也就是觉得他们赚这么多钱太可怕了，你知道的，如果你愿意的话，那就是那种表演性的愤怒。而他说，作为一个美国人，我无法理解的是他们怎么能赚这么少。这项运动里有这么多的资金，与美国体育明星相比，为什么他们花了这么长时间
for them to realise their bargaining power? Well, and the question I always ask when somebody kind of complains about how much footballers earn is, where do you think the money in the game should go? Is it better if it goes to the sheikh in Abu Dhabi or the hedge fund manager in New York but that's one of the interesting things about the globalized football isn't it that the club itself often makes remarkably little money and basically acts as a middleman to take money from tv companies and give it to footballers and their agents so you don't go
才意识到自己的谈判筹码呢？嗯，每当有人抱怨足球运动员赚多少钱时，我总是会问的一个问题是：你认为这项运动里的钱应该流向哪里？是流给阿布扎比的酋长还是纽约的对冲基金经理更好？但这就是全球化足球有趣的地方之一，对吧？俱乐部本身往往赚不到多少钱，基本上充当了一个中间商，从电视公司拿钱然后分给足球运动员和他们的经纪人，所以你不会去
you don't invest in a football club if you want to be rich because basically you're handing a lot of money to your... Well, you didn't. I mean, I think since financial fair play, regulations have come in over the last decade or so, I think now you can get rich owning a top successful football club. And the negotiations are going on now
如果你想发财，你不会投资一家足球俱乐部，因为基本上你是把大量的钱交给了你的……好吧，你以前不会。我的意思是，我认为自从金融公平竞赛条例在过去十年左右出台以来，我认为现在你拥有一个顶级成功的足球俱乐部就能发财。而现在正在进行的谈判
about the restructuring of the Champions League, I think will increase that. But that's only the very very top right? The very very top yeah yeah. And people who invest in football clubs now when they invest in them lower
关于欧冠联赛的重组，我认为会增加这一点。但这只是最顶尖的层面，对吧？最顶尖的层面，是的，是的。现在投资足球俱乐部的人，当他们在较低级别
down the idea is to get them up a division to essentially spin them and sell them on and a lot of the takeovers are leveraged so you're not actually investing very much of your own money
投资时，想法是让他们升级，本质上是转手倒卖，而且很多收购都是杠杆收购，所以实际上你并没有投入多少自己的资金
you're taking a debt that's got the club as a guarantee. Do you think that the kind of hostility to the money that star footballers earn is a kind of vestige of expression of class hostility? I mean, people don't complain about actors, Hollywood stars getting that amount of money.
你是用以俱乐部作为担保的债务来收购的。你觉得对球星赚取的大笔财富的这种敌意，是不是一种阶级敌意的遗留表现呢？我的意思是，人们可不会抱怨演员或好莱坞明星赚那么多钱。
Yeah. I mean, look, I think there's two things there. One is it kind of is disgusting that Mesut Ozil was earning 17 times in a week what a nurse would earn in a year. There's something wrong about that in a wider sense. But at the same time, yeah, I think there's a class and probably a race-based thing that there is something still that offends people about the idea of a young black kid from Lewisham making 20 million pounds a year.
是的。我的意思是，听着，我认为这里有两点。一方面，厄齐尔一周的收入相当于护士一年的收入的17倍，这确实有点让人反感。从更广泛的意义上讲，这有点不对劲。但与此同时，是的，我认为这里存在一种阶级和可能的种族偏见问题，当人们想到一个来自刘易舍姆的年轻黑人小孩一年能赚2000万英镑时，内心仍然有某种东西让他们感到被冒犯。
And what about the future? So football is becoming, I mean, it's incredibly popular worldwide, but it's becoming increasingly stratified, less competitive, arguably. Is there a scenario, I mean, this will be anathema to you, but there must be some kind of scenario at some point where football dies. I mean, everything dies in history. You know, nothing, people don't do chariot racing anymore. So at what point, how do you see it dwindling? I mean, let's say after we're all gone, what would be the sort of the process by which football would would fall from grace yeah i mean i think that's really interesting you know especially uh in the
那未来呢？所以足球正在变得，我的意思是，它在世界范围内非常受欢迎，但它正变得越来越阶层化，可以说是竞争越来越不激烈了。有没有这样一种情景——我的意思是，这对你来说可能是个大逆不道的话题——但总有一天，某种情景下足球会消亡。我的意思是，历史上一切都会消亡。你知道的，没有什么，人们不再赛战车了。那么在什么时候，你认为它是如何逐渐衰落的？我的意思是，假设在我们所有人都离开之后，足球会通过什么样的过程走向没落？是的，我的意思是，我觉得这真的很有趣，你知道，尤其是
context of these negotiations which which are happening at the moment about how the champions league may be restructured uh which essentially the rich clubs are trying to stitch it up so they get even more money and so they're insulated from the possibility of failure. But Agnelli, the chairman of Juventus, the biggest, most successful Italian club, he has suggested that football is not getting take up among 18 to 24 year olds. And I mean, he's clearly a clown. Let's not think about the bush about this. Agnelli is not a man whose view I would necessarily trust. But it's interesting he's raised this issue and he's suggesting modern attention spans
在这些谈判的背景下——这些谈判目前正在进行，关于欧冠联赛可能如何进行重组——富有的俱乐部基本上是在试图串通一气，以便他们能获得更多的资金，从而免受失败可能性的影响。但尤文图斯的主席、意大利最大最成功的俱乐部的老板阿涅利曾表示，18至24岁的年轻人对足球的关注度并没有上升。我的意思是，他显然是个小丑。我们对此不要拐弯抹角了。阿涅利不是一个我一定会信任其观点的人。但有趣的是，他提出了这个问题，并暗示现代人的注意力持续时间
mean that people are not going to be prepared to sit down and watch a 90-minute game. Not good news for test cricket. Well, quite. And one of his ideas is you sell subscription packages so you only watch the last 15 minutes of games, which clearly is ludicrous that's like watching
意味着人们不会准备好坐下来观看一场90分钟的比赛。这对板球测试赛来说可不是什么好消息。嗯，确实如此。他的一个想法是出售订阅套餐，这样你只需要观看比赛的最后15分钟，这显然太荒谬了，这就好像在看
the last act of a play or something that's completely demented his argument his analogy is if you're watching a golf tournament the only action
一出戏剧的最后一幕什么的，这完全是精神错乱，他的论点，他的类比是如果你在看高尔夫锦标赛，唯一精彩的动作
takes place over the last six holes and you're sort of like yeah but if if one player is already ten shots clear
发生在最后六个洞，然后你就会觉得，是的，但是如果有一个选手已经领先了十杆
that's actually the bit you want to see and equally if you turn on a game and Liverpool are already beating Burnley 5-0... Sorry, I keep picking on Burnley. I apologise. Our producer is a Burnley fan.
那其实才是你想看的看点，同样地，如果你打开一场比赛，利物浦已经5比0击败了伯恩利……抱歉，我总拿伯恩利举例。我道歉。我们的制作人是伯恩利球迷。
I didn't know that. You're going to get cut off, Jonathan. Why would you watch the last 15 minutes? It just doesn't make any sense. But I think the wider point are younger people still watching football there's definitely an issue
我不知道这个。你会被切断信号的，乔纳森。你为什么会去看最后15分钟？这根本说不通。但我认为更广泛的问题是，年轻人还在看足球吗？这绝对是一个问题
in terms of going to the game I mean I remember years ago it must be 15 years ago now talking to a director at Manchester City so this is before the Abu Dhabi takeover and him saying
就去现场看球而言，我的意思是，我记得多年前，一定得是15年前了，我跟曼城的一位董事谈过话——所以这是在阿布扎比收购之前——他说
his great fear was he'd looked at the average age of season ticket holders at Manchester City and in the previous decade it had gone up by eight and a half years. So it was the same people buying the tickets and kids weren't coming in. Because one of the reasons for that is it's really expensive.
他最大的担忧是，他查看了曼城季票持有者的平均年龄，在过去十年里，这个数字上升了八岁半。所以买票的都是同一批人，没有新孩子们进来。导致这种情况的原因之一是票价真的很贵。
When I started going, it was two quid or £2.50 for an under-16 to get in. And you were under-16 until you were 21 in those days, unless you were particularly unlucky with your development of facial hair or whatever but yeah if you were a parent
我刚开始去看球的时候，16岁以下青少年入场只要两英镑或两英镑半。而且在那些日子里，直到21岁你都算16岁以下，除非你在面部毛发生长或其它发育方面特别倒霉，但如果你是一个父母
if you were if you were a father with your three kids wanting to go to a game now you're talking about 150 quid to take them to a Premier League game
如果你是一个带着三个孩子想去看比赛的父亲，现在你得花大约150英镑才能带他们去现场看一场英超比赛
Jonathan I think we're almost into injury time but just on a slightly sunnier note, of course, there is a massive growth area in football,
乔纳森，我想我们快进入伤停补时阶段了，但换个稍微轻松一点的话题，当然，足球领域有一个巨大的增长点
which is women's football. And I did a kind of radio show, oddly, about this. You know nothing about either of those things, football or women. The Dick Kerr Ladies, Jonathan. The Dick Kerr Ladies. Dick's ladies ladies um and uh what was it lily par um the chain smoking toothless striker who could break a man's leg with a penalty kick and they were massive weren't they over during the first world war and after because there wasn't any other
那就是女子足球。奇怪的是，我曾做过一个关于这个的广播节目。你对这两者一无所知，无论是足球还是女性。迪克科尔女士们，乔纳森。迪克科尔女士们。迪克的女士们女士们，嗯，还有那个叫莉莉·帕尔的……那个烟不离手、没有牙齿的前锋，她可以用一个点球踢断一个男人的腿，她们非常受欢迎，不是吗？在第一次世界大战期间和之后，因为当时没有任何其他
football and then it got kind of crushed and evil industrialist men stopped the women from playing but now that is coming back so that is a huge growth area it should be a growth area yeah so yeah you're right the the the the normal league the the men's league the professional league which have been ongoing since 1888 is abandoned uh in 1915 and you then get a series of regional games happen, but also women's football really takes off. And the Dixie Co ladies would get crowds of tens of thousands. Then 1921, the FA decides to outlaw all women's football played on grounds belonging to clubs affiliated to the FA. So effectively, it kills it at a stroke.
足球比赛了，后来它被某种程度上镇压了，那些邪恶的工业家资本家阻止了女性踢球，但现在这项运动正在回归，所以这是一个巨大的增长点，它本该是一个增长点，是的，所以，是的，你说的对，常规联赛，男子联赛，自1888年以来一直在进行的职业联赛，在1915年被中止了，然后你看到了一系列地区性的比赛上演，而且女子足球真正腾飞了。迪克科尔女士们能吸引数以万计的观众。然后在1921年，英足总决定取缔所有在属于英足总附属俱乐部的场地上进行的女子足球比赛。所以实际上，这一下子就扼杀了这项运动。
Now, why they did that, I think has never quite been adequately explained. I think partly it was some kind of moral panic. There was something somehow unseemly about women playing sport. And it wasn't just football that women had, where women's sport was sort of a long way behind. You know, the Robert Cole's book,
至于他们为什么这么做，我认为从未得到过充分的解释。我想部分原因是一种道德恐慌。女性踢体育运动在某种程度上被认为是不大体面的。不仅仅是足球，女性体育在当时也远远落后。你知道的，罗伯特·科尔的书
You Were 30, talks about how there's very little record of women playing sports in the 19th century I think there were some England, Scotland football internationals in 1881, 1882 but it's clearly lagging a long way behind, there's some sort of sense that this wasn't
《你三十岁了》中谈到，19世纪女性参加体育运动的记录非常少，我想在1881年、1882年有过一些英格兰和苏格兰的女子足球国际比赛，但很明显它远远落后了，当时有一种感觉认为这
quite right, this wasn't quite proper but I think also the FA were driven by this fear that the clubs which obviously had terrible wars, had been getting no money coming in, a lot of players had been killed, that they were going to lose fans to this new form of the sport. And I think they were acting to protect that. And that ban is not lifted until 1968.
不太对劲，这不太正经，但我认为英足总也是出于这样一种恐惧：这些俱乐部显然经历了可怕的战争，没有收入进来，许多球员阵亡了，他们会因为这种新形式的运动而失去球迷。我认为他们采取行动是为了保护这一点。直到1968年，这个禁令才被解除。
So disgracefully late. And the Women's Super League only went fully professional two years ago, three years ago? Right. Well, that's's jonathan i'm blowing the whistle there it's full time um we've avoided the lottery of penalties can't thank you enough jonathan um absolute podcasting technical masterclass there um we are releasing the rest is history twice a week currently so do keep an eye out for us on mondays and thursdays please send in your questions we tweet the subject matters up for discussion about a week ahead. Just reply to either myself
所以这个时间晚得令人发指。而女子超级联赛直到两年前、三年前才完全实现职业化？没错。好了，乔纳森，我在那里吹哨了，比赛结束了。我们避免了点球大战的残酷抽签。乔纳森，非常感谢你。这绝对是一场播客技术的名家讲座。我们目前每周发布两次《历史余音》，所以请在每周一和周四留意我们的节目。请把你们的问题发给我们，我们大约在讨论主题前一周发推文征集。只需回复我和
or Dominic with your question. Thanks so much for joining us. If you run now, you can avoid the traffic outside our metaphorical stadium. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
多米尼克中的任何一人并附上你们的问题。非常感谢大家的收听。如果你现在就走，你可以避开我们这座隐喻体育场外面的交通。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史余音》。想要收听独家节目、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。